Welcome to AV Testing Podcast, your modern testing podcast.
Your hosts, Alan and Brent, will be here to guide you through topics on testing, leadership,
agile, and anything else that comes to mind.
Now on with the show.
Hey, it's Alan.
I am here.
Brent is not here.
Brent is now, believe it or not, in outer space, putting networking into one of the
satellites for Satya's special cable feed of the World Cup.
So instead, I have a guest I've had here before, who I've followed a lot.
Wonderful things to say about testing.
Have Kat Obring here today.
Kat, say hello and remind everybody about you and kind of what you're up to.
Hello.
Hi, Alan.
And thanks so much for having me again.
I enjoyed, really enjoyed our last conversation, even though, as I just mentioned, I don't
really remember what I told you.
I'll remind you in a minute.
That's old age and all that.
Yeah.
So I'm Kat Obring.
I'm the founder and sole employee of Kato Coaching.
I mainly do courses, workshops for people.
I also publish a lot of LinkedIn, if you want to find me there and can look there.
Mainly what I want to talk about, or mainly what I am interested in is good decision
making around QA and quality, really more than QA, and how we can help teams to
make those good decisions.
And obviously, so this used to be a lot around DevOps practices and shift left, shift right,
all of that good stuff.
But now the times have changed, of course, and we're all talking about AI.
So I have to talk about AI.
Because AI, I think, AI really demands good decision making more than most tools
do.
And you have to make good decisions to get good use of any tool, but AI specifically.
There we go.
Yeah.
It sure does.
And we'll talk about AI in a minute, but that's actually a really good way of putting one
of my peeves is people used responsibly and with good decision making, AI is very
powerful and very helpful.
A lot of folks either rely too much on it or not enough on it and take the human
decision making part out of it and then say, oh, AI is shit.
It won't work for us.
And it's like, no, no, no, no.
We'll get there.
It's been a couple of years because I took six months off from the podcast and it's
been a couple of years since you were on the podcast, but it's interesting
looking back.
I'll remind you, we talked about things like, well, there was at the time
you were talking about deleting the test column from the Kanban board.
Oh, yes.
Still a good thing.
Still a good thing, too.
But we talked a lot about it very much in line with what Brent and I have
been talking about with and well with with modern testing, but also with Lisa
Crispin, Janet Gregory on whole team quality and what that really means.
Again, a lot I'll get off of my rant on people that can't use critical
thinking to define to look at statements like that.
So a lot of just ownership and you and test coaching, which we and even
people credit, they say, Brent, you and I, you and Alan have been talking about
coaching and testing for a long time.
And even in and I like to point out that in Lisa and Janet's book, the
first agile testing book, chapter five or whatever it is on test managers as
the testament, I'm paraphrasing, because I haven't read the book in 15
years, but it's the test manager role often moves to test coach.
So the idea has been there a while and it makes.
Sense because test ideas is the value of is like one of the biggest values of
testers we can think about things where like, how does that need to be tested?
What could go wrong?
What do I need to understand more about this to instill confidence, et cetera?
And then we talked a lot about your, your, your test coaching,
which I thought was awesome.
So are you still doing some of that Cato coaching?
I absolutely do.
Yes, which I love.
And then, and then the world shifting into AI and it shifted a lot.
Like I took, I left the workforce last April.
And AI was around and it was popular, mainly, but man, it has in my time away
from work, it has accelerated more.
So I'm, I'm curious what your take has been, like how, what has it been
like for your work and your world watching AI explode a little bit?
And there's both, there's all kinds of things to talk about here.
It's like how you use it, how people are reacting to it.
Like, but you are hands on with this for a lot of your work.
What are you seeing?
Um, I am quite hands on with AI and have been pretty much for whatever, since AI
tooling became generally available really.
So I would say probably the last two and a half, three years, I probably started
around the time we last talked, just not quite as much as now because, and
when I say AI tooling, I use a lot of this to automate things around my
business, for example, because I'm a one woman business.
So the more of the kind of drudgery admin stuff I can take away is the better
that is for me, because the more brain power I can put into actually running
my business and doing thinking about what I can do better and thinking
creatively about things.
So, and I think that is where a lot of AI tools really shine, right?
For example, I have a recurring client.
I write a variation of an invoice to them every month previously that
involved getting a CSV from them, transferring that somehow into zero.
It is not, you know, an ordinate amount of time, but it takes some time.
And now I have an agent that I dropped the CSV into, and then it just
automatically produces my invoice, right?
So this is only, I don't know, this has reduced a 30 minute thing once a
month to two minutes once a month, right?
But over time, and that can be reused, of course, for other things as well.
So, and it didn't take very long because I basically let the
gen AI build the agent itself.
I fine tuned it with a few things, but you know, so all of that said,
I think in testing the situation is really interesting because I really come
a lot about the kind of dichotomy of a camp kind of rejoicing, saying,
hooray, AI can do all the testing.
We don't need either those pesky testers anymore or spend time working
on those pesky tests, depending on who you talk to, right?
And then the other camp who is very much, no, no, no, no, no.
You cannot let AI test anything because you can't trust anything
that comes out of it.
And it's a false dichotomy, right?
I mean, you're going there.
This one pisses me off, too, right?
But you're kind of like, yeah, but neither of these things is actually true, right?
That really bugs me.
So it's interesting.
I'm going to build on something you said around.
You took this task that was a little mean, you know, you could do.
It took 30 minutes.
It wasn't the most exciting work of the day.
And the thing is, it's not just that it was 30 minutes of work versus two minutes.
It's that work that did not bring you any joy at all.
Yes.
Other than the paycheck coming in at the end, eventually.
It's just we don't.
You and I, we're people that like that work.
The outcome of that work did give me some joy, right?
But yeah, absolutely not.
No, right.
So, you know, 10, 15, 20, going back even farther years ago,
automation had we had the same story.
Oh, automation is good.
We could automate this stuff.
What we're seeing now, and I'm curious what you think about this,
because I've seen this talking about platform development and tool development is.
Yeah, we can.
It's only it's software.
We can write anything.
The barrier on that is so much lower.
Now, there's a lot of things we go with.
I could write software to do that, but it would take me,
you know, 30 hours to replace a 30 minute job.
Just just the ROI isn't there.
But now it is.
Now, if we can, if I don't like there's something I want to automate.
I can automate it quickly.
And you see, you're nodding your head.
You're seeing the same thing.
It sounds like why that is what I think is an excellent use case for AI.
Unfortunately, I'm not seeing as much of that as I would like to see.
Oh, well, you know, so it is quite interesting because again,
people sitting in these kind of force for or these kind of camps, right?
And the people who generally reject.
The idea of AI being useful for anything.
They they obviously they don't think it's useful for anything.
So they don't think about these kind of the opportunity where you can build
a small tool that is very specific to your context and your work workload.
Right.
And make that easier for yourself.
Take something some of that friction away somehow.
And the other other camp.
Well, they probably do that, to be fair.
They maybe push it a little bit too far and maybe don't think enough
about the decision making around that, because that is something that I find
is suffering a little bit in both camps, actually decision making.
Right.
So my my my old my old topic, I like this.
I like to think about making good decisions and how you make good decisions.
And I see a lot of kind of knee jerk reactions right now,
or kind of impulsive reactions and very little of careful evaluation of facts
or doing what testers do define what a good outcome would look like.
And then see if we if we actually getting that good outcome
or are we just getting something that is super impressive
or something that is absolutely not what I was expected expecting.
Right.
Yeah.
And I want to tangent because we do that on this podcast
a little bit on decision making because
one of the things I noticed many, many years ago is I'm a good I'm good at pattern matching.
I didn't notice that I've always been good at pattern matching and seeing things.
I noticed that the leaders that were very effective and the ones I really liked were
all really good at decision making, regardless of the amount of data they had.
They just they were just they would confidently make a decision
and not be afraid to change course if they were wrong.
So I'm kind of curious and like you talk about it a lot.
What word is good decision making?
I don't have an answer for this.
I'm going to ask you as a hard question.
Where does good decision making come from?
How do people get to be good decision makers or good at making decisions?
How do we get well, so like many things, I think practice helps a lot.
So you can practice making good decisions.
And I think there are frameworks that you can use if you are struggling.
I have just actually given a keynote to our friends in Indonesia for their ISQA
conference.
And I talked a little bit about that.
If you look back in history, or even if you OK, let me let me reframe that.
That book, Daniel Kahneman, Thinking Fast and Slow,
was very popular in the testing sphere a few years ago.
It was with good reason.
I think it's an excellent book and I think it is a book that
I really highly highly recommend people read.
And he talks about the system one and system two, right?
System one is the fast decision making where you react before you want to react, really,
where you just kind of impulsively respond to things without thinking them through.
Where system two is kind of the deep thinking, collecting facts,
sitting with your facts for a little while before you make a decision.
So very simplified.
But, you know, that's kind of the two things.
And there are, if you go back in human history and look at philosophy, for example,
through many cultures, there are frameworks that have enabled people to go from system one to
system two, because as humans, we default to system one.
And that is what I see a lot around this AI discussion as well.
Yeah, that's a great insight.
So any framework that allows you to move yourself from system one into system two
around that is a good framework.
And so I was totalist is a good one.
Right.
So ask, reflect and respond is that that can do it for you.
Phrase, quest, ask a question.
Look at the answers without thinking about how you react to them.
Then play it back to make sure that you have understood your questions.
And then then kind of keep probing, keep probing.
This is what testers do naturally.
Anyways, we are very good at question asking questions.
So we can apply what we normally do as to this whole AI thing anyways.
Right.
Another thing is what we are really good at as testers is define what outcome you're after,
like very specifically.
Don't don't throw something like I want the thing to, I don't know,
create test cases for me.
That's maybe a little bit broad.
I kind of narrow it down a little bit and define what is okay for you.
What amount of hallucinations are you willing to live with?
What amount of rework cycles are you happy to live with?
How much time are you willing to spend in correcting the output you're getting?
You find all those things up front.
Yeah.
Now I'm thinking I'm again building what you're saying.
I love that answer to especially starting with just practice making decisions and
make some wrong ones too.
I think a lot of decision paralysis comes from people afraid to make a wrong decision.
I've made a few hundred thousand wrong decisions in my life and probably more on the way,
but as long as we learn from them, it's great.
No problem.
With AI, now I think AI can be a tool to help you move from system one to system two
and both with using AI for coding, using AI for collaborating on ideas,
or using AI to come up with test ideas.
There is and I hate the term prompt engineering.
I think it's stupid.
But being applying that decision making a judgment, applying judgment to the prompts you give
AI when using gen AI can be very powerful.
You mentioned about talking about the outcome and then also asking the gen AI.
And again, it can be wrong and it's not and once you understand how they work,
you understand why they're wrong, why they can be wrong,
and that can help you make better prompts in the first place.
But you can ask it, I'd like to understand all the areas that this particular web page could have
input issues and how would you test those?
I'm just making up stuff on the fly here.
And then it can give you those ideas and you say,
what other types of bugs on this page may I miss because of this approach?
And it will give you some ideas.
And what I find is that collaboration, that back and forth,
it may not give me the perfect end all answer,
but it gives me an answer that makes me think of more questions.
And let me go back to way back.
I think it was Ken Caner's maybe it was box.
I don't know somebody a long time ago talking about definition of exploratory testing,
which has probably changed 18 million times since then,
but they said simultaneous execution and design of tests or something.
And we can do a lot of that with gen AI a lot faster.
And I use it in that way for a lot of different things to help me think through things.
Maybe not even necessarily to generate the output I want,
but to help me think more deeply about what I'm trying to get done
because it's the way it pulls information.
It can just, it gives me prompts that make me,
it almost prompts me back in its answers to think about things
in a different way or more deeply.
Yes, exactly.
And sorry, I realized I said I was told this,
I meant Socrates, of course, right?
So I was talking about the Socratic method.
Yeah, the letters are going to come pouring in.
Well, you know, anyways.
No, but you're right.
And that is what I do.
I have actually built a couple of skills.
It's a little bit overkill for an agent,
but a couple of skills that help me think certain things through just the way you have.
So I describe in the scale very clearly how I want the AI to interact with me.
And that is big because I use it as a discussion partner.
I wanted to ask me questions in a specific way.
I wanted to recognize when I'm trying to cop out of an answer, for example,
and instead then go in and ask me and force me to get a little bit more detailed,
maybe, or a little bit more precise.
So, yeah, I am totally with you.
I think it can be an amazing tool for getting into that system to thinking.
But you need to, of course, guide it to be that,
which again, I think that is the,
so for me, the big promise in Gen.
AI really is that we can all build the tool that we need.
We can form it into the thing that we need, right?
Provided that we are clear on what we need.
Yeah.
So I want to ask you questions.
I've been out of the day-to-day testing, even test coaching for many years now.
And one thing I noticed on teams when I was doing this more was
recognizing when a tool or code would help you be more an effective tester.
Before AI, like, oh, I have to do this thing.
It just takes me hours, but I got to get it done.
I said, and I told them, well, we can automate this.
And so I don't write code.
That's okay.
Well, let's collaborate.
Just recognizing that something can be automated
or understanding when the power of code
can help you do more effective or efficient testing.
That was a problem 10, 15, 20 years ago, all the time.
How can we take this, like this, I don't even call it a mindset.
This notion that I'm calling a notion.
The ability to recognize when something can be done more efficiently
using the computer to help you was missing from, not all,
from a number of testers I worked with, you know, 10, 15 years ago.
Today, the ability to recognize when the computer can help you be more efficient,
I think, is even more important because testers are all a lot of testers.
Those same testers are freaking out
because things are moving even faster than they ever have before.
So I'm curious, it's a long build up to a question of, are you like,
how do you help testers recognize when the power of a computer,
whether it's AI or automation,
can help them do something more efficiently or effectively?
Or are you seeing that problem anymore?
I do see that problem.
And I think we are seeing a lot of not super helpful answers around that.
Again, right?
So again, I think it all comes back to how do you make decisions
and how do you observe and how you make decisions
in large part depends on how you observe the world around you.
And that applies to also to finding opportunities for automation
and asking yourself, is this a valuable automation opportunity?
Or is this just something that I could automate,
but that ultimately gives me no benefit if I automate it, right?
And what I try to give people is tools to think through that.
Rather than, so another way to phrase it,
I don't have a general answer to that.
I can give you a process that I think is helpful.
And that process generally is, if it involves you making decisions,
you probably should not automate it.
You should automate everything that helps you make a decision faster,
better, with more information,
or whatever it is that you need for your decision making, right?
But do not outsource the decision making itself.
That's it.
That's wonderful.
That is so concise and so accurate and so helpful.
Yeah, I've been thinking a lot about some of the previous podcasts
we've talked about AI comes up a lot right now
because testers are understanding what to do.
I have two questions.
I'll ask the first one first
because that's usually the way things work better.
In a nutshell, how do you advise testers
or what do you think testers should be doing now
to lean more into AI and use AI to help them versus,
talk about that false dichotomy of,
it'll solve all my problems versus it'll solve none of my problems.
What guidance do you have for testers to find the right way
to leverage AI in their current jobs?
Like what should they be doing?
So I think, well, this is probably so.
I try to be short.
I'm not sure that I will be able to.
No, we just want the information.
So one of the things is being,
before the one camp that I talk about
where people don't want to touch AI,
I don't think that is a tenable situation.
Right now, I think whether you like it or not,
I don't think that particular genie
is going to go back into its bottle.
Nope.
So the first thing I would definitely recommend everybody
is try to use it.
Try to find a use case for yourself
where you can define an outcome
that would make your life better
and that you think your AI tool or gen AI or whatever it is.
I think most people just get co-pilot,
Claude, whatever, Codex, maybe, right?
And that gets thrown at them.
So try to find a thing that is friction in your workflow
where you think this is mechanical, mechanical.
I mean, we are knowledge workers,
so we don't really have mechanical tasks,
but kind of the equivalent to a mechanical task.
How can AI take that away from me?
Can it do that for me?
Can it? I don't know.
Maybe part of your day involves sifting through 10,000 logs, right?
That is something computers are extremely good at.
Oh, yes. Very, very, very good.
So build yourself a little skill
that takes that away and just presents you
with a report of things where you actually need to look
rather than look at all the things
that we can sort out safely, immediately.
That is one thing.
The other thing I think is,
if I was still working as an active tester,
I would probably learn about AI events
and how to do those well,
including using LLMs as a judge, specifically.
Because, again, a thing that I hear quite a lot
is that, yes, the human in the loop
is going to be important,
but the human in the loop cannot be the human
that reviews all the pull requests, for example.
That is not going to work.
No, there's too many coming in.
Right? Because that kind of counteracts
the efficiency increase we have.
You're just shifting the bottleneck a little bit.
Right. Yeah. Sorry, go ahead.
Yeah. And the quality of those code reviews,
if done by a human, are not going to be great
because you have too much of them.
You have not been involved in creating the code.
It's the quality of those reviews is going to go down.
That's just in the nature of it.
Something I talk about a lot, the AI,
we're generating code so quickly.
We can't review it all.
They need some AI assistance.
We shifted the bottleneck.
But I do want to ask you,
you may not remember, but a couple years ago
when we talked, and time is weird,
it could seem like even longer ago,
you talked about the ability for testers
to be able to read code.
And I had predicted even before then
that in the world of AI, the ability to read code
was going to become more important
than the ability to write code.
And that part, I'm not very often right
in my predictions, but that one
is becoming more and more true all the time.
So I'm very, pat myself on the back here.
At the same time, we can't review all the code.
So I'm curious, what's your take on that today?
Because, well, it's kind of a leading answer.
I know, because we can't read all the code,
but what do you, or maybe not.
Maybe we use AI for it.
I'll ask a better question.
Is that as important, more important,
less important than it was two years ago,
the ability for testers to be able to read code
and understand it?
That is a difficult question, actually, I think.
I think as I asked it, I realized
it wasn't as cut and dry as I thought.
It wasn't a softball.
Yeah.
Okay, so I'm slightly circumvented.
What I'm going to say is this.
When I recommend people learn to write code,
really, mainly, what I think they need to achieve
is to get up close and dirty with the product
of their work or the product they work with.
And that is not the outcome of the code.
That is not the software application.
But it is also the thing that drives
the software application that is the code.
And I think I probably said that back then, right?
I think testing is one of the very few
kind of professions I know
where people think they can judge the product
without being able to wield the tools,
which has always baffled me.
But that is a whole different brand.
So I think that that part is still as true
as it always was.
And I think it has never been easier
to teach yourself to interpret code.
You will not need to write every line of it.
You will not need to be able to understand
every line of it.
But you will need to be able to not have fear
going into the code base and maybe,
and again, computers are very good at that,
pointing out a bit that you're interested in
and let the AI explain to you what it does.
Yeah, it does a really good job at that.
And I was thinking while you were talking,
you could, as a tester,
if you didn't understand code,
to still copy and paste the code change,
particularly your testing or set of code changes
you're testing into an AI tool
and ask it as a tester,
excluding manual test cases,
what's my best plan of attack here,
in some better words.
And it'll probably give you some reasonable ideas.
It's not going to be complete and maybe wrong,
but it's going to give you some ideas to look at.
And from that, again, because I think,
to me, and you talked about this well also,
using any one of the GenAI chatbot tools
is it's an interactive experience.
It's not like, for me,
some people use ChatGBT or Claude like a search engine.
It's fine, but it's so much more powerful
when it's a conversation
and use it to collaborate and vet ideas.
And I think a lot of folks
miss out on that little bit of nuance.
Absolutely agree.
And again, so I think it has never been easier
for people who have not grown up writing code
and who have not spent the majority of their time
in works writing code.
It has never been easier to get close to the code
and understand what's happening there.
And I think that is really important.
I also think maybe I can make
a little prediction of my own here.
I usually stay away from those.
But currently, what I am seeing
is that the boundaries between roles
are shifting and they're getting fuzzier.
Good, finally.
We've been looking for this for decades.
Right. And I think that is just going to continue.
And that is not just between developers and testers.
That also involves product people, of course,
because now every product person
can go and whip up a prototype in an afternoon
rather than vying for two weeks of development time.
I'm going to go one step farther.
I think the vibe, I don't know if you saw
this anthropic thing from a month or so ago,
but they had a coding contest and a lawyer won.
And in fact, a programmer,
the highest placing was fourth place.
And the reason is they didn't talk about this.
My interpretation is the reason is
the domain expert knows so much.
This is why, at least for the lawyer who won,
he knew all the rules around zoning.
He's trying, he's building some zoning regulation tool,
which was great.
It solved a problem for him
that took hours and hours of work.
He was able to create a program
that would do all the work for him.
Wonderful.
Now, I think something I'm thinking about
as I go back to entering the workforce,
whether it's consulting or full-time,
we'll find out, is the whole organization can,
air quote, once again, the podcast code,
which is a pro and a con.
The people in marketing come up with solutions
for their stuff, which is great.
It's hard enough to teach developers
the difference between works and production ready.
And that jump from the marketer,
hey, it works.
Can we deploy this to the world?
There's the quality challenges
and the things that have to be done.
You and I understand these because we've done it.
We've been doing it for years and years and years.
It's not that we need to test quality into it,
but there could be regulatory things.
There could be the gen AI tools
often miss security type issues.
Things like there's all kinds of hardening.
We call it in the biz that needs to be done
even on some of the best non AI written code.
So I'm curious on your thoughts on that idea.
What should I mean?
I don't say should I'll say today
the entire organization can create code.
What does that mean for testing and quality?
Well, it kind of, you know, like you say,
we have been talking about this for years.
And I think, okay.
So, and this is the part where I don't make predictions
because I think none of us really can predict
where this is all going to lead in the end.
Absolutely.
I think a lot of this is up in the air right now.
It feels like it is a meaningful shift
in how organizations are structured
or that we will need to see a meaningful shift
in how organizations are structured.
However, I know that I also thought this
about agile and that never really happened.
I know, I know, I know.
So we shall see.
But I think and you mentioned domain domain knowledge
and I think that is exactly the point here.
I feel that the team of the future
will have to have still some specialization
in those domain knowledge.
But I think the execution of what a team creates as output
will be a more collaborative effort.
We also think need to be clear about differentiation
between personal tooling, organizational tooling and product.
Because it is a difference whether I write a small tool
that I use every afternoon for five minutes
or whether we write a tool that the organization uses
for something, maybe collaborative thinking.
That would be interesting.
I would really like to see some tooling around that
evolve out of the core.
The capabilities we now have with AI.
Or, like you say, whether we let that lose
on a general public that may need protecting in many ways.
Right.
And there's even, yeah, I like this.
And I don't have any answers.
It's just something I've been thinking about.
Yeah, the personal tool, have at it.
Little automations that save your day,
make an invoice easier, go at it.
Then there is deploying internally at the organization.
So it's like another ring of protection.
There could be privacy issues.
Even in the best well-intentioned companies,
there can be bad actors and go,
oh, I can leverage this and see all of your email, Kat.
So it was like my email,
there's nothing exciting in there, have at it.
But that happened to me at a product at Microsoft once.
Someone made a mistake in some token caching
and all of a sudden they saw someone else's email.
Internal only, but still a big, big, big deal.
So those things need to be covered, handled.
And then even if that internal tool
is deployed to the cloud in some way,
which a lot of them are,
there'll be even in a private AWS,
there is initial hardening has to happen there.
And then if you're going to make this,
oh, we want to share this with some customers.
Oh, new level of rigor needs to be done here.
And just it's a different kind of education.
There's almost doing training.
I've done training before internally at Microsoft.
And at Unity, there's a whole set of training around this.
It goes with like, you would never teach
some of these secure coding practices and ideas
or secure, I don't even call it coding,
just security mindset to the folks in marketing
and sales and legal.
But we're at a stage now where I think we do.
And it's an interesting world.
So that moves me into another question
I want to ask.
You've been in quality coaching for quite a few years
and been very, as far as I can tell,
pretty successful at it.
I'm curious on your thoughts on this idea.
You've talked a lot about helping teams with AI
and we've talked a lot about teams
that can't figure out the right place
in that false dichotomy, that spectrum I'll call it,
of where to use AI.
Do teams need AI coaches?
And how much of your job is AI coach now versus test coach?
And I don't have an answer for this.
I'm just thinking like, I think there's a market there
for people to not just not come in and be an AI expert,
but to help people understand the right level of AI
for their context and their problem set.
But curious on your thoughts.
I have been thinking about that.
In fact, I have been offering
kind of specific coaching sessions for that.
And I am going to do a cohort, a test cohort on that.
Let's see if people want it, right?
So I think yes.
And I think those actually sit in a very similar space,
the quality coach and the AI coach, right?
Again, I think a lot of that has to do with
how do we make decisions?
Can we help people use those?
And maybe there's even overlap
with the deaf role, actually, right?
How can we help people make the best use of tools?
How can we help them use these tools safely?
All of that kind of goes in there.
I think it's just another example of...
I don't like to say, right,
role X is dead or anything like that.
But I do think we will see, like I said before,
fuzzy kind of boundaries between roles
and overlap that move into different directions.
So yes.
And yes, and we'll speak the words
that have been said for over a decade now.
Test is dead, but test isn't dead.
It's kind of like the king is dead, long live the king.
Test is evolving.
It's evolving faster and faster over the past,
not just the AI area, since I don't know,
since I've been doing it for a very, very long time.
And what I see, I'm not going to go deep into this,
but just to build on what you said,
although it's evolving,
some people don't want to change and evolve with it.
And what's happening is,
there's always been a space for those people,
but they're getting obsolete faster
than they ever have before.
Probably.
I mean, yes, we all have a certain amount of inertia,
some more than others, right?
And I agree, but this kind of throws us back
to what should testers do with AI, right?
Again, I think the best way to form an opinion
about something is to use the thing, right?
Absolutely.
It's hard to form an opinion about a tool
if you've never used the tool.
If I only ever have a hammer,
I don't know if a screwdriver maybe
could be super useful for me.
There's a story I've told for a very, very long time.
There was a time in my career
when I decided I should read a book about testing.
So I read a book about testing.
I thought, oh, okay, I get it so much better now.
And then I read another book.
I thought, oh, well, some of these ideas aren't,
they're conflicting.
And then I read a third book.
I thought, oh, and it wasn't until after I got that far
that I began to form my own opinions.
Then I read more and I could critique as I went.
It's, if all you have is a hammer,
if all your information about how the world works
comes from that hammer,
yeah, the world's gonna be a nail for you.
I think the ability to form opinions.
So we talked about,
actually, we can go back to another thing
we talked about before.
We talked about test zombies,
the ones who look at the script
and follow the script exactly
and miss everything going wild over to the sides.
I think AI, here's my thought on that.
We've seen that happen in the past.
I'm just gonna blindfully and optimistically
think that never happens anymore,
although I know I'm wrong.
Should testers move or,
I'm forming a question here.
If I was like a good reporter,
I have these all written out in advance,
but I think as I go,
it's like it's exploratory interviewing.
Is testing move with AI tools,
is testing moving to being more
of a high level critique versus execution
or are both still equally needed?
I think, again, this kind of brings us back
to the testing being the profession
that thinks it can critique the thing
without understanding the tools, right?
So I think both have always been equally important
and I think both will remain equally important.
I think the tooling is shifting as always
and I think the level of insight
we can get from that tooling is maybe changing.
Again, so I think it is easier than ever
to look under the hood of any application
these days for a tester.
So for any tester,
I think there is no longer any excuse to say,
no, the only testing I do is I use the thing as a user.
But you're not the user.
Exactly.
And then I think that was never a good argument.
I know that we agree on this, right?
So use those tools.
And I think, actually,
because GenAI is so malleable,
although those AI tools that we have,
they are so malleable,
every kind of flavor of tester
can use them in a way
that plays into their existing skill set.
They will have to expand that skill set, of course, right?
But if you happen to be somebody who delights
in looking at a UI all day long,
you can use AI to make that more meaningful.
If you are somebody who delights in finding,
maybe finding tickets in your backlog
that don't have great acceptance criteria,
you can totally build a little tool
that is going to help you do that.
If you want to improve communication in your team,
I'm fairly certain you could build a skill
that can help do that as well.
Yeah, that's interesting and valuable.
And I'm going to build on that with a long intro.
A question is going to be far too long.
For context, there were about 230 episodes
into this podcast.
Brent and I started this 11 years ago,
maybe 12 years ago by now.
As a way, we were seeing testing change
as Agile was getting popular.
And again, Agile was very popular elsewhere.
Microsoft just slowed a catch up.
And we noticed the role change.
We noticed the roles fuzzing
and things moving faster.
And we started talking about
what we talked about on the podcast.
We wanted to help testers understand
how they could fit in with this new world
where quality and delivery were more important
than trying to test quality
and in doing some of those things.
Those things are all exponentially,
and I don't use that term lightly,
more important because things are moving
much, much faster.
Testers are much, much more often feel
like they're the bottleneck.
And they're worried about relevance.
I think there's straw men posts.
I don't know how many of them are real,
but LinkedIn, as you know,
is filled with, oh, a company never named
fired all their testers.
And this quality thing happened.
You need to have testers.
And yes and no.
But how about a well thought out argument with it?
And your post is generated by Gen. AI.
It just drives me crazy.
And you and I spend enough time with the tools.
You and I can spot in a second
that post is written by AI.
I could tell.
Right.
So what are, if you're at the risk of
stealing some of your consulting ideas,
if you're what couple bits of advice,
I won't even number them.
What's the advice you give a tester
trying to stay relevant
in this world of fast moving AI?
What are the things they should be learning
or doing or thinking about more?
Like, how would you like,
if I came to you and said,
hey, Kot, I am on a test team.
I feel less and less relevant
as the team moves faster and faster.
I'm worried about my career.
What sorts of things should I be doing
to stay relevant in this world?
Funny enough, I don't think my advice
to all of these changes has really changed
all that much over the years.
I would still say exactly the same thing.
If you want to stay relevant,
especially in your,
so there were two or three things, right?
In your current team,
things are moving faster.
You feel like you're becoming the bottleneck.
Well, figure out one specific thing
where you can stop being the bottleneck
and remove that friction
and then move on to the next thing
and to the next thing.
Don't look at it as a systemic issue,
which it is, admittedly, right?
But no, just solve one problem at a time
and you will be extremely relevant.
If you are the person who can help the team
spend two minutes per test run,
less waiting for those tests to be finished,
you have no idea how relevant people
will think you are.
Absolutely.
That is such a great answer.
And it's how I moved from,
and I had always been more
on the tooling side of testing,
but it's how I easily and successfully
moved from the testing world
into infrastructure and platforms,
which is I'm a professional bottleneck
identifier and remover.
I see patterns and I can use data
to find out where the bottlenecks are.
And I just, one at a time, remove them.
And our modern testing principles
talk about theory of constraints.
It makes so much sense.
It's all about what is our biggest pain point
or what's blocking us the most.
Even knowing that is a huge step forward.
And then as a member of the team,
regardless of your role,
not even solving it yourself,
but often just identifying it
and then figuring out
whether it's by yourself
or ideally collaboratively
because AI to help you.
Reduce or eliminate that bottleneck.
And again, it's not eliminating the bottleneck.
It's reducing it until it's not
the biggest bottleneck anymore
and then finding the next one.
Find a real problem to solve for your team.
Yeah, that's it.
Don't just be the information provider,
the test executor,
the one-dimensional employee,
I don't even call it tester.
We don't have room for one-dimensional employees
in knowledge work.
And I don't think we ever had, to be honest.
And that's why my advice
really isn't changing all that much.
We tolerated it though for a long time.
Exactly.
Though there was one other side to that,
and again, that also hasn't really changed
all that much, which is
don't confuse domain knowledge
with product knowledge.
So testers often pride themselves
on their domain knowledge
and I think that is true,
but I think often what they mean
is product knowledge,
which is important to you
in your current situation.
Absolutely.
Domain knowledge, however,
is a little bit bigger.
Yes.
And use your domain knowledge
to build your product knowledge,
not your product knowledge
to think you have domain knowledge.
I think that is the other thing.
And again, with the tools we have today,
that is easier than ever
to actually build on that
and to build yourself
a structured way of learning about that.
It is.
And it's maybe one final topic
before we get into closing.
We hinted at this earlier.
I thought, oh, I'm not going to go
into that soap box,
but I'm going to go into that soap box.
There's a lot of testers that say,
I'm the voice of the user.
And that's great
if you want to tell yourself that.
Then I asked these same testers,
what do you do to understand the user?
And they talk about their product knowledge.
And it's like, no.
And the way to be the voice of the,
I mean, you're not the user.
You never are.
I don't care if I'm a professional writer
and I go to be a tester
on a word processing app,
I'm still not the user.
I'm closer, but I'm not.
Because the user is,
ideally in a successful product,
a collective of a lot of people.
And if you want to be the voice of the user,
that starts with not just data,
customer data from telemetry,
understanding how they use the product.
But in today's world,
people talk about the products
on Reddit and forums and here and there.
And talk about pattern matching.
I could point an LLM at a Reddit forum
and say, summarize the complaints
people have about this product
and this forum.
And I can get a whole bunch of ideas.
Like that is,
like you're still not the user,
but at least you're making an effort
to understand the user.
And what drives me wild
is the folks who think
that I use the product a lot.
So I'm the voice of the user
and they're not.
And they're just anyway,
curious on your thoughts on that.
I think we're of one mind here.
There's probably some other ideas you have,
but how do you,
what do you do when you account
counter testers and say,
I'm the voice of the user?
I don't encounter that many of them.
Maybe that is just because
I am so publicly outspoken
about my opinions that they don't contact me.
And like you say, by the way,
so I actually do have a workflow
if I want to look at something specific,
like a product,
I often will use perplexity
to search for Reddit forums,
take the list of that,
stick it in a notebook.
And then I can,
so notebook LM, Google, right?
Great tool.
One of my favorites, actually.
And then I can interrogate that.
Then I have a collection
of what people say
and I can ask it questions.
And that tool is then going to go
and find that.
So I don't even have to do anything myself
other than find a bunch of links, really.
And yes, I have never understood that.
So I'm the voice of the user.
I got my first job in testing
because I was a heavy user
of the product
that I then became a tester of.
Again, that was product knowledge.
That was not domain knowledge
because I had zero domain knowledge.
I just knew the product very well
and people liked my attitude
and that's how I got into testing.
The other thing is,
often you find that kind of thinking
combined with,
we find the problems
that nobody has thought of before.
And yes, there will always be some problems
that you will find
that nobody has thought of before.
But frankly, most of what these people think of
is just bad product discovery
and that should never have made it that far.
So if that is your job,
you're really just a cleanup crew
and you should solve a whole different problem.
Another one of my P's is,
when testers think they're the cleanup crew,
that's not a very aspirational career.
Right.
I mean, important.
Yes, in many, many ways.
But you know.
Brent would point out right now
that in one of my presentations,
what I liked,
I talked about testers being
the champions for the user
and having the superheroes.
I said, but really,
but really you're the cleanup crew
and I show the people shoveling up
after horses in a parade.
So which one do you want to be?
Actually, neither.
It's not an economy.
Kat, the time has flown by
and as I expected,
we violently agreed on a lot,
but I think I'm super happy
that the three listeners
will get some great insights.
There's some quotable stuff on here
and I'm not sophisticated enough
to do cool quotes on my podcast
and anything, but it is,
man, I really like the way you think.
I will post to your LinkedIn
and your consulting site.
Anything else you want people to know?
Anything else you want to say?
Anything else?
Shout outs, credits, other stuff
before we close for the day?
Well, no, thank you.
Just so pleased to be here.
And yes, it was a great conversation.
I really enjoyed that again.
So let's do it again in three years.
We'll do.
We'll make it a yearly thing.
I'll send you a meeting.
We'll figure it out.
I would like that.
Yearly tradition.
Anyway, love talking with you.
The thing is, if we talk again in a year,
the world will have changed
that much hugely more.
It'll be a whole new conversation.
It's interesting.
It's a new conversation
with the same roots.
You just talk about different things.
That's the funny part.
Yes, I totally agree.
So in a year from now,
we will probably be talking about
which AI models are still alive
and what token costs had to do with that.
Okay, I'm going to save that.
And actually, I can save that
because the last little bit is
that you talk about notebook LLM
a little bit ago.
I have, again, with the help of AI,
I use whisper AI and some Python
to create transcripts
of every podcast episode
that are uploaded to a GitHub repo
or where we have access to.
And then notebook LLM
is connected to those.
So I can go query any question I have
about anything ever been on 230
plus some other side things.
It's like 250 episodes of A-B testing
and find out anything I want.
I can ask, what episode was Brent eating
while recording?
And it'll tell me
what are the times I made fun of him.
So it's great.
I said notebook LLM.
You potentially can even just stick a link
to the podcast in there.
That's new maybe since I've been playing with it.
Or I didn't know it was there.
You never know.
I know it works with the YouTube videos,
but I don't know if other video works.
We'll find out.
Maybe I'll try that sometime.
All right.
Again, Kat, it has been amazing.
Thank you so much.
This has been A-B testing.
Thank you.